all right I was thinking about doing
this uh for the daily cancellation today
but it would be uh be a bit redundant as
our potential cancel e has already
canceled himself and um yet there is
something to be learned from his
self-immolation I think he fed himself
into the wood chipper and he has
provided us with an important cautionary
Tale in the process uh and you know and
the moral of the story is don't jump
into a wood chipper really if you needed
that lesson here it is uh literally or
figuratively don't jump into one so CNN
reports a middle school teacher in
Pflugerville Texas has been fired
District officials said on Monday after
videos posted to social media showing
the white teacher tell his students that
his race is the superior one
quote last Friday November 11 the
Pfluger flugerville ISD officials were
made aware of an inappropriate
conversation at a teacher a teacher at
Bowles Middle School had with students
during an advisory class Pflugerville
Independent School District
superintendent Dr Douglas Killian wrote
in a statement as of Monday morning
November 14th the teacher in question is
no longer employed by Pflugerville ISD
and we are actively looking for a
replacement uh videos of the
conversation question were posted to
social media last week now
from the way that the media is reporting
on on this incident
you might imagine that the teacher went
on a wild unhinged white supremacist
rant
which in some ways it was wild and
unhinged
but I want you to listen to the to the
tone and uh anyway let's listen to that
and then we'll talk about it
some ethnocentric which means I think my
race is the superior one
is better than all no let me finish
I think everybody thinks that they're
just not honest about it I'm not racist
though I like all types of comments did
I say I don't like people
you said you are what
you already said you're like you're
racing everybody's a racist at that
level no she said you are racist
no I'm not saying it again I've said it
enough so you're right
yeah I don't think I got respect for him
no more bro you know you should have
more respect
now by the way the district has made
counselors available to students who are
traumatized by this uh by this event
somehow I don't think the councils will
be necessary because the students seem
to be more amused by it than dramatized
I mean they're laughing about it and uh
and you can tell the teacher as he's
talking like you can see him realizing
as he's talking that he shouldn't be
saying this and uh and you could see the
regret set in and then he I think he
tells one of the students to put their
phone away but it's too late because
he's already on camera he forgot the
student that was sitting right next to
him
here's the point here though
that this teacher is actually doing
exactly what the woke crowd tells him to
do
right this this is this is CRT in action
this is what it is
um
white people are inherently racist
this is what we're told this is what all
the race Hustlers will tell you so Robin
deangelos and and uh ebermax Kennedy and
all the rest of them
uh in fact if you as a white person tell
them that you are not racist they will
tell you no it's racist to say you're
not racist because you are racist and so
what you need to do is confront your
racism and admit to it
uh you have to confront your confront
your racism admit that you're racist If
you deny that you're racist that's only
further confirmation that you are racist
and that's racist in itself white people
are inherently racist black people
cannot be racist because of structural
you know it's racism is Prejudice plus
plus power and blah blah blah
um and and then what they also say is
that we need to start having
conversations
right have conversations about race
and so this teacher
attempted to apply all of that is that
we're gonna have a conversation about
race
and uh I'm I'm gonna admit that I'm
racist because this is this is what
we're supposed to do that's the woke
thing we're all inherently racist
you got one detail wrong though and
maybe if he got in this detail right he
wouldn't have been fired
um but he says well everyone is racist
that's actually that's not what CRT
teaches CRT teaches that only white
people are racist
which is an important distinction for
them not everyone only white people
now we we if you were to play this video
back
rewind it and if he was able to do that
again he probably would just keep his
mouth shut but
um if he could phrase it differently
imagine if he had said everything the
same
he said I'm ethocentric I'm racist but
all white people are all white people
are inherently racist
then I think this becomes a totally
different thing I don't think he gets
fired for that
so he was attempting to do
what the war crowd wants him to do
got the details a little bit wrong
now he's fired
um
of course even if you gotten them right
I mean it's uh it's this is this is this
is a thing you're a racist either way
it's it's sort of like uh go back to the
Witch Hunt days and uh If you deny that
you're a witch then well that's what a
witch would do you're lying so you'd
executed but if you admit that you're
witch well then you're a witch so we're
gonna execute you for that
this is the it's the quintessential uh
you know
get woke go broke situation what you
just saw there
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]